do you develop distributed applications
or systems made up of lots of
microservices if so you've surely had to
deal with issues where users complain
about the service being slow
in a distributed system it's often hard
to figure out which dependencies causing
it
this is where distributed tracing comes
in
we covered using open telemetry to
capture and analyze latency from
distributed applications in the previous
episode if you haven't watched it we'll
link to it in the episode notes but in
brief we want to create traces for user
requests and spans for the service to
service requests whose latency we want
to analyze to determine which services
may be contributing the most to the
overall latency experience for our users
open telemetry is an open source library
that allows us to easily instrument our
services and capture traces from them my
name is yuri i'm an sre at google cloud
and today i'm going to show you two ways
to instrument your services with open
telemetry i'll cover easily getting
started with automatic instrumentation
and using manual instrumentation for
maximum control welcome back to
engineering for reliability
[Music]
let's have a look at a simple
application that has a front end that
serves user requests and makes its own
request to a backend to retrieve
additional data we'll use this for both
of our examples today so ideally we want
to capture the latency of the overall
request that's perceived by the user the
latency of the backend request as seen
by the front end and how long the
backend processing takes
the front end of our application is
written in flask and it uses a request
library to make back-end calls
the back-end is also a flashcard when it
receives a request it does some
processing before returning a response
to use automatic instrumentation we can
run both our front end and back end
using the open telemetry instrument
command the command will try to
automatically detect packages used by
our code and apply automatic tracing
instrumentation on them we get
distributed tracing exported to
cloudtrace without having to make any
code changes let's take a look
our front end is running locally
using the open telemetry instrument
command
instructing it to send traces to
cloudtrace
and the backend is running locally as
well using the same command
let's send a request to our application
and confirm the response
in the cloud trace ui
we can find the resulting trace
it's comprised of multiple spans
the root span is the
overall request
and we can see how long it took
it was made to our service running on
localhost on port 8080.
the first child span is the backend
request
it was also made to localhost
but on port 8081
which is where our backend service is
running
so this is how you can use open
telemetry automatic instrumentation to
capture traces across distributed
services
without the need to modify application
code at all
that was really easy but there is a
caveat we couldn't create a custom span
to time back-end processing without
adding instrumentation in the code so
let's have a look at how you can
manually instrument your service to
explicitly control how spans are created
we'll link to the full code sample in
the episode notes but let's start by
reviewing our front end code
[Music]
first we need to import the necessary
open telemetry libraries that will let
us manage spans and context propagation
between our services we'll use the
request contacts to send information
about our trace to the back end so that
it can append its own spans to it
next we configure our exporter to send
traces to cloudtrace
finally we're ready to make our backend
request we create our root span that
will serve as the parent for the
subsequent spans
next we create a span specifically to
time how long the backend request takes
lastly we make a request with http
headers that will carry the span context
to our back end
in our back end service we first extract
the span context from the incoming
request headers
we then create a dedicated span using
that context to time how long our
backend processing task takes now let's
run our services and inspect our trace
in cloud trace
in this example we also have our front
end running locally but this time we're
using the basic python command
our backend is also running locally
using the same command
we can confirm that our application is
responding by sending a request and
confirming the response
now we can go to cloudtrace
and find the resulting trace in the
trace list
the trace has our root span
the back end request span
and now a dedicated span for back-end
processing
for each of these we can see exactly how
long they took
which allows us to figure out exactly
where the time is spent in serving the
user request
so this is how you can use manual
instrumentation with open telemetry
to send request context over the wire
and use it to append child spans from
downstream services
thanks so much for watching today we'll
learn how to use both automatic and
manual instrumentation with open
telemetry for distributed tracing of our
python services and understand latency
in distributed application
i hope this helps you to keep your
services reliable and your users happy
don't forget to like and subscribe to
never miss out on more engineering for
reliability with google cloud see you
soon
[Music]